for the first time in six decades there
were no mass celebrations to mark cuba's
most important revolutionary holiday
only posters of former president fidel
castro alluding to the need for national
unity
july 26 marks the anniversary of the
1953 attack on the monkava military
barracks
that eventually led to the overthrow of
cuba's former batista dictatorship
authorities have cancelled the usual
commemorative celebrations
blaming a severe spike in covet 19
infections
and deaths
but this month's unprecedented
anti-government protests
were also a factor i moved
there are many young people that didn't
live through what i lived
who've seen better times they want to
live better given the propaganda of the
enemy
politics is like that
there are reports of hundreds of
so-called counter-revolutionaries
detained and being held in prisons
throughout the island
over the weekend the government
confirmed that some 60 protesters had
been sentenced in summary trials
accused of inciting public disorder
one of them was artist angelo troya
whose mother
reissa gonzalez says that her son and a
dozen others
was sentenced to a one-year prison term
without a lawyer present
my son raised his hand and told the
judge that he had the right to an
attorney
he had the right to be defended and that
he had not been given the opportunity
he was very angry and then they
immediately came up to him and i said
please shut up please
shut up then they put the handcuffs on
him
opposition lawyer iloila who's now
living in canada
says authorities are trying to silence
the voice of defendants
they are trying to eliminate all the
facts
all the arguments that can a speech or
that can be saved
in a position to do what the government
is doing
right now that's why they are trying to
maintain lawyers
out of those process
meanwhile hundreds of cuban americans
supporting the protesters in cuba
marked the july 26 anniversary in front
of the white house
but on the streets of cuba's capital
demonstrations of any kind
were conspicuously absent to see
newman al jazeera